the Wild and wacky Halls of Greendale
Community College have hosted a ton of
big stars and these are the ones who've
also gotten schwifty on Rick and Morty
Joel McHale played Jeff Winger the de
facto leader of the main Community crew
a once successful lawyer his prestigious
degree from Columbia University is
revealed to be a sham forcing him out of
his career in a bid to return to his
high-profile lifestyle Winger enrolls at
Greendale Community College to receive a
legitimate degree where he becomes the
leader of a colorful band of Misfits
after Community wrapped up in 2015
Mikhail went on to star in The X-Files
and even played former Community co-star
Chevy Chase in the 2018 comedy a feudal
and stupid gesture however he eventually
reunited with his community boss Dan
Harmon for the Rick and Morty season 3
episode Rick mancing the stone in this
episode Rick transports his
grandchildren Morty and summer to a Mad
Max Style universe filled with chaos and
vehicular Warfare Mikhail voiced the
role of hemorrhage the leader of a group
that terrorizes the wastelands summer
Falls for Hemorrhage but their love
story doesn't last long Rick eventually
helps the tribe become more civilized
leading the Macho Hemorrhage to adopt a
simpler and more docile way of life
notably summer isn't the only Rick and
Morty character to enjoy a brief romance
with a character voiced by a former
Community star
in the Rick and Morty season 5 episode a
rick convenient Mort Alison Brie voiced
a fictional eco-conscious superhero
named planetina while on an adventure
with his grandfather Morty encounters
planetina and immediately Falls for her
surprisingly the shy superhero also
takes a liking to the high schooler and
the two begin to date much to the dismay
of Morty's Mother after hatching a plan
to save planetina from being sold to a
rich Sheik the two spend their days
together saving the planet unfortunately
Morty learns that planetina places more
value in protecting the planet than she
does in Saving human lives something
that forces the young man to break up
with her Brie Rose to prominence after
appearing as the do-good straight A
student Annie Edison in community the
youngest member of the group she often
struggled to have her voice heard and
was taken advantage of for her
Proficiency in school throughout
Community she shares a will they won't
they relationship with Jeff Winger which
is ironic considering the two actors
also served as love interests for
different characters in Rick and Morty
the Animated Series doesn't seem too shy
about bringing back guest characters and
planetina's story also wasn't quite
wrapped up entirely yet so there's
always the possibility that Bree's
character and Morty could reunite once
again
and now an elemental punch that's too
hot to handle
Gillian Jacobs made quite the splash
when she joined Community as Brita Perry
an activist struggling to find meaning
in her life through Community College
Britta appeared as a series regular in
community throughout its six season run
after the star wrapped up her time as
Bretta on the comedy she went on to
appear in a number of Netflix series
including Judd Apatow's love and the
Fear Street Trilogy Jacobs has also
spent the years since Community ended
lending her voice to animated characters
after voicing characters in Adventure
Time American Dad and long live the
Royals Jacobs briefly played an unhinged
superhero in Rick and Morty Jacobs
appeared as Supernova in the season 3
episode vindicators 3 the return of
world Ender in the episode a drunk wreck
concocts a plan to terrorize a team of
prolific superheroes by putting them
through life-ending challenges and
puzzles that take a page from the saw
franchise after a number of trials and
tribulations Jacob's Supernova manages
to make it out alive despite surviving
her Mayhem it remains to be seen whether
the character will ever return to the
series perhaps the character could even
team up with Alison Breeze planetina at
some point in the future
after appearing in a recurring role as
Dean Pelton in the first two seasons of
Community Jim Rash was promoted to a
series regular in season three the fan
favorite character is best remembered
for having a crush on Jeff and for his
many elaborate and sophisticated
costumes while starring as the dean of
Greendale Community College rash
co-pinned The Descendants which nabbed
him a best adapted screenplay award at
the Oscars after Community called it a
day the star quickly made a guest
appearance in Rick and Morty the Oscar
winner appeared in the season 2 episode
Big Trouble in Little Sanchez as glax
glow slim slom an Intergalactic marriage
counselor who tries to help Beth and
Jerry reconcile their rocky relationship
naturally not even the greatest marriage
experts can tackle their marriage and
Chaos ensues IGN praised the episode and
the Beth and Jerry storyline writing
between Jim rash's guest appearance and
the wacky violent battle that ensued the
Beth Jerry storyline was unusually
entertaining seeing as Bethany Jerry's
relationship has evolved since the
second season it seems unlikely that
rash will return as the character
anytime soon the star more recently
voiced a character in solar opposites
another animated series spearheaded by
Rick and Morty co-creator Justin Roiland
you may already be learning something
important
throughout its six season run Community
boasted a variety of guests and regular
appearances from high profile and
established actors a decent chunk of
them have also popped up in Rick and
Morty throughout the years perhaps the
most obvious is Keith David who appeared
in the final season of Community as
Elroy potashnik a failed inventor the
actor continues to occasionally appear
as president Curtis in Rick and Morty
John Oliver who most people probably
know is the host of HBO's Last Week
Tonight appeared in community as Ian
Duncan a psychology professor at
Greendale in 2013 Oliver also voiced an
amoeba named Dr Xenon bloom in the Rick
and Morty season 1 episode Anatomy Park
Nathan Fillion who appeared as a
Greendale custodian in community also
shows up in Rick and Morty as a galactic
secret agent who wants access to Rick's
formula for interdimensional travel in
the season 3 episode the rickshank
Redemption seeing as Rick and Morty is
still airing it remains to be seen if
other cast members from community Unity
will appear in the animated Sci-Fi
series perhaps Community series regulars
Danny poodie Donald Glover Yvette Nicole
Brown and Ken Jung will get their shot
at voice roles in the show too
[Music]